l'instant les oligarques ils ont perdu
quoi un lieu de lagos à un truc à droite
mais rien de très important et le peuple
est souillée puni de tout est absolument
de tout c'est dur a dit n'apprendra
guillaud bah moi parler de courage sauf
que c'est obscène en fait moi je trouve
que c'est pas du tout le boss c'est pas
du tout le duc je trouve que c'est juste
un pleutre qui à miami qui nous donne
des leçons dont je trouve que c'est
dégueulasse parce que aujourd'hui on est
en guerre et on est soit avec soit
contrée ya pas tergiversé à tordre de
comme ça et pardon mais booba toujours
fait de la politique tout ce qu'il fait
et géraldine il ne donne aucune leçon de
cynisme elysées son communiqué je
l'avais je n'ai pas signé pour ça ni
aucune leçon non mais booba ne fait que
de la politique mais il vient ici ibos
messia il fait la leur mais donnera mais
il fait que de la politique qui disent
pas que quand il paraît que vous vous
n'en faites pas oui j monique girard non
mais moi si vous nous en donner tout
laisse tous les jours non mais oui mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que je nous en
donnaient tous les jours des leçons de
morale et des leçons de moralité d'axa
vous nous avez fait mais comment sa vie
avait payé pour ses lego 10 leçons oui
la médina mais sauf que la nuit se
trouve que vous n'avez pas le monopole
de la bonne conscience humaine et
mondiale géraldine keystone le son est
bâillonnée quand on n'est pas bonne
route malaisie mais bon ça fait deux
heures comparé les non j'imagine valeurs
communes et interrompu par les accents
vous allez parler tous les jours alors
allez-y terminé en quoi c'est un
problème de parisse mais non mais c'est
pas ça c'est que les deux dossiers on
sait que le manche de son duel à me
donner chez vous at il donné aux autres
son analyse il finisse et j'ai rien à
dire mais j'ai comme envie de savoir que
c'est un dîner c'est dégueulasse et
qu'il est du côté des collabos en disant
ça et c'est dégueulasse voit la salle
toi même tu veux pas dire et non mais
laissez la finale à quatre l'épinard
dans quels sont les pays qui ne veulent
pas les sanctions pour la russie
aujourd'hui médias je connais tu es là
la syrie et trois dictatures voilà et
donc booba et de ce côté là excuse moi
il ya un problème il faut être un peu
plus un peu plus subtil que ça compte
il ne prend aucunement partie dans le
conflit lui c'est un artisan ça mais
nous avons un style est là pour divertir
les gens ici qui dit rachète à ibos
messia parce qu'il ne veut pas faire de
politique justement il y à vous de voir
les voiliers qu en est-il donc vous
laissez pas parler les jours ils veulent
remercier les jours
voilà il ne fait pas de politique et je
me mets à sa place il a signé un deal
avec une marque ya quelques années
aujourd'hui cette marque prend parti
dans un conflit géopolitique alors
qu'elle ne l'a jamais fait auparavant ça
lui pose problème il se sent utiliser et
donc d'où cette petite phrase on n'a pas
signé pour ça pour moi il a totalement
raison
signer pour sa géraldine ça veut dire
quoi j'ai pour moi booba fait tout le
temps de la politique donc je sais pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui vous jouez les
offusque en dix ans booba ne fait jamais
de politique il ne fait que de la
politique vous allez loin quand vous
parlez de collabos en titre in china
béjaouis alors toi oui quand ils
tweetent sur charlie hebdo il fait de la
politique quand il parle que harry harry
roselmack c'est un traître sur villers
le bel il fait à mon avis mon avis mais
c'est dévié lula le droit de donner son
avis un citoyen engagé comme moi et on a
droit de donner notre avis ou géraldine
il n'appartient à personne
voilà il dit genappe je n'ai pas mis les
mais laissez-moi parlé une seconde j'ai
réagi parce que là on ne joue pas mais
ça fait dix minutes que vous nous
asséner de grandes leçons de vie de la
loi à la loi tunis menzel
entre la droite julien non mais on peut
lui résister à miami elle doit durer une
année de répit ne résiste à personne il
dit il dit je n'ai pas signé pour ça
vous rompez joron avec le nom de nancy
il dit je ne veux pas travailler avec
une marque qui me prend en otage et qui
portent atteinte à ma liberté c'est un
homme libre qui parler vous le comprenez
à l'envers il ne veut pas être assimilé
à quoi que ce soit il dit moi je fais là
à john dalli